they came for miles and miles to see
what happened here
but there wasn't much to look at at the
accident site
the earth was scarred and the grass was
burnt
and the airliner was broken into a
thousand or more pieces
157 people perished on this rocky plane
and the foreign office says nine or more
britons are among their number
yet the aircraft was new and the captain
was experienced
a team of investigators are trying to
find out what went wrong
and the answer lies in there it's hot
it's dusty and it's very unpleasant but
they've got a lot of work to do
the technical teams sifting through the
soil trying if they can
to recover parts of the aircraft and
those who flew on it
but it isn't easy this structure
disintegrated
over several hundred square meters
data captured by the boeing 737s flight
recorders
will be crucial to the investigation and
these orange boxes
have now been recovered one question is
key
did the on-board computer fail like that
of an identical plane
which crashed off the coast of indonesia
last october
yet there is another source of knowledge
here locals
who saw the aircraft hurtle to earth
i looked up and saw the plane trying to
turn around
but it fell quickly the sound of the
engines changed
and it slammed into the ground i was so
frightened
i ran away he told me
this is a time of crisis in ethiopia
their airline is a symbol of national
pride
and government ministers did not want to
comment
nor did these army chiefs when we
approached them can you give us an
update on the situation
i think but the united nations
invited the public to share its grief
it held a minute silence in new york in
honor of at least
22 un employees who lost their lives
and the secretary general said it was
one of the worst
incidents in the organization's history
our colleagues were women and men
junior professionals and seasoned
officials hailing from all kinds
all corners of the globe and with a wide
array of expertise
they all add one thing in common a
spirit to serve the people of the world
and to make it a better place for us all
ethiopian officials say they have
contacted all the victims family members
and begun the process of identifying
human remains
but this windswept place will remain an
international
accident scene for a long time to come
john sparks sky news ethiopia